now it's just a few months since the uk
launched the homes for ukraine visa
programme to try to host at least some
of the refugees forced to flee their
homes but is the scheme working joined i
by the former justice secretary sir
robert buckland hello to you sir robert
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning we have one of your
constituents on the program a little bit
later on she's come here um from ukraine
and is now trying to help others come
here too how is the scheme working
yes well sophia volovik is on later with
uk is a shining example of how somebody
came here in recent months part of the
homes for ukraine scheme and now is
helping other people link up with
ukrainian refugees
through her own website and her own
local organization called swindon
welcomes ukraine uh i think this scheme
ha from a slow start has been working
pretty well i think there's still a lot
more that needs to be done to match up
families uh here in the uk with
ukrainian refugees and i think it's
through initiatives like sophia's that
we will you know get that greater pace
going
um and make sure that as many uh
refugees as possible have that friendly
warm welcome that we all want to give
them bearing in mind the horrific uh
experience that they've been through uh
continues
um indeed how many peop we did promise
many many tens of thousands of
ukrainians i'm sure you can give me the
exact figure refugees could come to the
uk how many have come so far how many
more are we expecting and how long can
they stay
well i think first of all with regard to
the the limit of stay i think it it
really is open-ended bearing in mind the
the fluid nature of what's happening in
ukraine uh the exact figure the
up-to-date figure is not in my head i'm
afraid okay i think it's uh quite a few
tens of thousands of 80 000 comes into
my head as the immediate figure um
though i can be corrected on that uh i
think that uh we've got all these
various schemes going the the homes for
ukraine scheme the the other different
uh
schemes that were set up i think
sometimes that could be a bit confusing
um and therefore it's really important
that uh all of us uh mps indeed all
local agencies work out how we can best
match up uh the demand with the supply
that we we obviously have and the number
of people who have registered is still
you know i think well in excess of the
actual matches that have been made with
regard to accommodation um and you know
that work has got to continue and just
because uh you know it was very much in
the headlines a few months ago um just
because it might not be as much in the
headlines as it was doesn't mean it
isn't still important and that
organizations like sophia's don't have a
huge role to play there's an awful lot
of home office red tape there isn't
there still um we were um featuring
yesterday four-year-old alika zuberz she
was sent to uh back to kharkiv after
being considered an unoccupied
unaccompanied minor i should say she was
here with her uh grandparents not her
parents and and she's now been denied
access to the uk twice we need to sort
that out surely
look kate i think that's right i i think
clearly in cases like that the basic
humanity
of the case should shine through uh you
know i'm all for due process and getting
things right but uh we do need to make
those important judgments and have the
flexibility
to make uh the value judgments that i
think you know anybody would make in
those in those circumstances bearing in
mind the very young age of that little
girl um you know i think this country's
reputation is second to none for our
welcoming nature and our generosity to
refugees ukraine has been an amazing um
outpouring of love and support and i see
it here in swindon with with local
organizations like sophia's like the
swindon humanitarian aid partnership
that i helped
organize here in swindon uh you know
we're just one of many towns and cities
across the country that are doing our
part to welcome
friends in need uh and to do our part to
help particularly women and children
because it's in the main women and
children who are coming here and are
separated from their their husbands and
their sons who of course in many cases
fighting to defend their homeland
um you are let's talk briefly should we
about the tory leadership campaign you
are team sunak um
what do you say to allegations he was
mansplaining last night certainly
talking over the other candidate
yeah i think i think it got lively um
what i'm looking for in both leadership
candidates is that sense of energy and
urgency and purpose and i think um you
know it's good to see
that energy from rishi sanak he clearly
wants to hit the ground running from day
one and get on with a number of
priorities and i think in in a debate
like that okay where you've got
differences about how to manage the
immediate economy um i want to hear
actually that lively exchange and at
times yes it can be a bit feisty i
myself can you know get feisty in
debates as well but i think that at the
end of it all there was that mutual
respect between the two of them that
shone through
in the last 10 minutes or so
these people have known each other well
they've sat around the cabinet table
they're capable of having a mature
debate and in fact the content of the
debate i thought was pretty good
i'm sure that the sky debate will
provide more uh insight into their
thinking and let's hope we can get into
that sort of quality argument rather
than earrings and uh prada shoes that uh
i think we we got into at one point last
night unfortunately
yeah well that's certainly what i've
been cramming for um and that we'll
certainly be asking both sides for
clearer understanding on some of those
major topics come next thursday at eight
o'clock here on sky news just before i
let you go um sad news about mr trimble
yes lord trimble uh was an outstanding
leader political giant and nobel peace
prize when i had the honor of knowing
david for a number of years uh and
daphne as well is his wife who to whom i
send my condolences this was a man who
came from a very strong unionist
tradition but then who put peace first
and he reached out to his opponents
because he wanted to see peace in his
beloved northern ireland and he with
others on the other side of the debate
the sectarian divide achieved that in
the belfast good friday agreement and we
owe david a huge debt of gratitude and i
think back with great sadness today that
i won't see my friend again but great
pride uh
about what he achieved not just for
northern ireland but for our country and
indeed the wider world okay uh thank you
very much indeed sir robert thank you
thank you